this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
monday the 28th of february
the joint is brought to you by on it
when it comes to supplements honor is
number one in my book alpha brain will
change your goddamn life i'm on a cycle
now i'm ready to rock but it all starts
with you go to honor.com right now
look at the great list of supplements
that they have
if you find something you want jump on
the bandwagon start with alpha brain
it's the company's breakthrough
if you don't like it
they'll send the product back
and you keep your money and the product
that's how they run it over and on it so
go to honey.com
prestonjoeychurch
and get 10 percent off your first order
and from the heart of new jersey the
joint is brought to you by draftkings
listen we got a tremendous fight this
week it's ufc 272
covington against mazdaville stepping to
the octagon and draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner the ufc
has a knockout offer for you ready we're
going to start this with a dollar now if
you still got your 200 credits
from the super bowl like you told me you
had this is gonna be easy it's a dollar
on the main event
and if you win you get a hundred dollars
and free bets no matter what it could be
a first round knockout a majority draw
or double knock out you snow matter the
outcome you get paid laid and part laid
[__] if sportsbook isn't available
in your state yet never fear uncle
joey's here ufc 272 has free draft king
pools
everyone can enter a free pool at to win
10 000
in prizes answer a handful of questions
like how long will the fight last who
will walk out the winner and follow
along to track your results so do me a
favor it's monday download the draftking
sportsbook app today whether in new york
new jersey put in code joey throw down a
dollar on ufc 272 main event and get a
hundred dollars and free bets no matter
the outcome that's code joey this
saturday at draftkings sportsbook
restrictions do apply
see
show notes for details
21 over
and if you have a gammon problem go to
1-800 gambler if not
let's get this party started download
the free app or download the daily
fantasy and let's win some details here
the joint is also brought to you by
c b d lion when it comes to cbd lion
cbd is king whether you want the
capsules the bath ball the the tape the
cream listen just do me a favor go to
cbd lion
and read and look at the third party lab
results if you like something i tell you
start off with the tinction
the high level 15 milligram 100
milligram tinction will set you free
pressing co joey or joint and get
off delivered to your house now
the joint is also brought to you by one
of my favorites and easiest whether you
have a small business or a large
business you need this and it's
stamps.com if you run a small business
the time and the effort you put into it
is anything but small so time is money
don't waste either on repeated trips to
the post office skip the trip and focus
on how to take your small business to
the next level with stamps.com print the
official postage right from your
computer and save yourself some guidance
spend less time at the post office and
more time making your customers happy
listen we've been with stamps.com over
10 years now my wife i don't know what
you do without them stamp.com gives you
access to all the post office and ups
shipping services you need right from
your computer with all the discounts you
can't find anywhere else get started in
minutes printing official postage for
any letter any package anywhere you send
stop overpaying for shipping with
stamps.com
sign up with promo code joey for a
special offer that includes a four week
trial free postage digital scale no
long-term commitments go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and enter code joey now let's
get this party started it's monday jack
hey how you doing
come on
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here february 28th the last
day of the [__] month we did it
in between the inflation the wars the
[__]
[__] the racism uncle joey's here to
get the weak start on the right
[__] foot
i talk about inflation because i'm
finally starting to [__] see it uh we
went to get mercy some pants the other
day
and my wife was like wait a second we
used to buy these same [__] pants for
they're up to [__] 40 and all that my
wife is like telling me all these price
things oreos are up you know
i don't know when they're gonna stop but
hey [__] all that [__] we'll figure it
the [__] out we'll put it together and
we'll keep [__] plowing through this
[__] tip
top
magoo my head goes out my heart goes out
my head goes out i'm [__] stoned
don't worry i got my little [__] ice
cream cake
little live resin hitter oh my god i got
listen i never even knew what live resin
was i'm not gonna lie to you and tell
you i knew i don't guys i'm an old man i
know reefer you know what i'm saying all
sudden they started doing vapor pens
the vapors were okay they weren't taking
me to where i needed to go sometimes in
a hotel room in the morning a vapor
would work so i gave them up why [__]
but then i took my little sabbatical
from reefer
abx sent me some [__] live resin
those you plug in they charge [__]
tremendous i remember one day i went to
jimmy's on sunday football and i brought
one with me and i had to come back and
take a [__] nap you know i was stoned
to the gills i was like what the [__] is
this i was falling asleep at his house
and then uh
ice cream shop sent me these these are
just raw ways
i gotta tell you something they hit like
a [__] mule so if you're in the area
stop by and get one of these little
[__] live i don't even know what live
resin is i could lie to you and tell you
the molecule i don't know nothing i just
smoked it you know what i'm saying i
know nothing i'm one of those idiots i
don't know nothing about trees i don't
know about [__] how to
grow [__] weed i grew weed one time
in my whole life
snowmass village
1986 i grew weed i was doing a good job
with it
and then one night i was smoking
bazookas that's when you put the cocaine
in the joint i ran out of reefer so i
took the plants cut them and smoked i
don't remember nothing i don't know
nothing about nothing but anyway
let me take a little hit to get the
[__] day started
i've been watching uh you know i told
you guys i watched the [__] wire for
like uh
i don't know two months
and we didn't even call dominic back i'm
gonna get dominic back in a few weeks uh
what i did i went right to oz listen
i don't know what else is on tv so i
just wanted to see all these great hbo
shows
i got hbo max so i said let me let me
put on ours
for you guys that don't know oz is a
show about prison
you know and it's the typical just a
regular show about prison with all these
characters going in and out you got your
italians you got your muslims you got
the blacks you got the irish you got
just you know a typical [__] you got the
bikers
you got the aryan [__] world you know
and it's so weird
when you watch something like that and
you've been locked the [__] up like i
was locked the [__] up you know
and i wrote this book the book is done
like i told the patreon people on friday
my book is done we wrote it i want to
give
a shout out to erica florentine thank
god i bumped into her
uh we've been writing this book for 13
[__] months
it's done
i love it with all my heart you know but
writing a book gave me a and moving back
here
gave me a big [__] reflection point
like i don't know if it was in the cards
or what but when i moved here
maybe three months later i started
writing the book and then
i you know because i had i wasn't going
to go on the road so i knew i had to do
[__] something so i go okay
you're not going to go on the road joy
but this you got to be doing something
you got to do something you're just not
going to sit on your [__] hands thank
god mike kept bugging me to start the
podcast we went back to the podcast but
that wasn't enough i still had to do
something so i said [__] it let's write
the book you know nobody gets out of
here live so let's write the [__]
book
and i tell you man while being here and
telling the first
you know
ten chapters of growing up and stuff
like that
it at home a different way you know by
that time i had gone up to the cemetery
and saw my mother's grave i got into the
neighborhood so
you know i i brought back a job it jolts
your memory a little bit when you go
back to the neighborhood and park your
car and walk around
so the first 10 chapters were easy to
write i mean they weren't nothing's
[__] easy to right in my world
because i got so many things going on in
my [__] head i got chinese people
yelling i'm hearing missiles from
ukraine you know russia's got a [__]
a fire thing that they [__] burn you
with did you see that at the border they
have like these fire things look at you
flamethrower they just [__]
vaporize you i need one of those [__]
flamethrowers a lot of people i like to
[__] vaporize
just for fun you know what i'm saying
but anyway elon gave one to jail did he
a flamethrower [__] i gotta borrow it
from next time i go down there
but uh it's funny how
when i wrote the prison part of the book
i really paid extra attention to it
because i knew
what that had done for me
there was death and
kidnappings and stupidity and drug deals
yeah that's all included
but
but if you really
think about
the turning point in my life what
because listen like i was telling mike
when he came here if you would
if we would have wrote the book the way
my life happened and you were to read it
after like
10 chapters you would have said joey i
keep reading this stuff over and over
and
it it doesn't change it's like
every six months you try to get clean
you try to get go decent you try to
become a [__] decent american and
then
six months later you're starting all
over again
it really got [__] old and monotonous
so we gotta
put all that [__] together eliminate a
lot of the stuff that didn't you know
that didn't contribute to the story i
wanted the book to [__]
tell you what was going on in my head at
the time what how i was seeing it
so it's funny that i'm watching his eyes
lately
and it made me actually go back to those
prison chapters again we already wrote
them they were already in my old file on
the computer i just wanted to re
see what i had put out there to the
world
if it was accurate enough if you know
because remember i was [__] withdrawn
at the time you know this had
i was withdrawn for a year and i didn't
know what the [__] was going on i i'd
like to tell you i was i don't know what
the [__] was going on we get on the
phone me and erica talk for an hour and
that night i go what the [__] did i talk
to erica about this i have no idea i'd
have to check my [__] notebook and
see what year we're on or what situation
we're on but
not to take anything away from anything
i think the prison for me was
it was a turning point
and you know
it's so weird i got the call on a friday
that i was going to go to prison on
monday
and i think friday and saturday i was
rattled but then it's like everything
else in my life
i woke up sunday and i was prepared to
take what they were given
like i was just prepared you know like
when i went to the knee surgery
like i didn't want to [__] get the
surgery
but i seen some [__] chubby dude
[__] pull up and he took a beer out
and [__] and i'm like i don't want that
to [__] be me
and i remember when the day of the
surgery you know what i'm a [__] guys i
usually start complaining my knee hurts
i don't feel good i give myself excuses
i got up i took a shot any breakfast i
went down to brick hospital i walked in
they did it there was a little
complication with my [__] they
couldn't find the vein to stick the iv
in all the [__] time
because they put in your [__] hand
you know what i come in from a fingering
contest that my veins are going to be
popping out my [__] hands
so
it's the truth like i don't know in the
morning my veins ain't i gotta lift some
weights and do some push-ups and eat
some pork chops and roll some joints and
crush up weed once you crush up wheat
all the veinstreet the veins come out
but if i go on there in the morning i
can't find the [__] but anyway i
don't
know how we got on the [__] talk of
the vein
but
the uh
the [__] prison thing like
friday and saturday i was thinking of
split
sunday i woke up and i'm like i'm taking
what's coming to me
and i'm gonna do the best i can the
first thing that [__] ed k bash told
me
was not
to get in the circle jerks
he goes i want you to avoid the circle
jerks when you go to prison
i want you just to [__] be in a
library yeah that's what i do
that's what they call circle jerks
circle jerks circle
a circle jerk is
four guys talking
okay
when you see
you look out into the [__] like and i
noticed it on ours also like when they
show the scene of the
the i don't know what they [__] call
them the pods okay a pot is maybe
a pot is maybe 32 in vicks
two in vic for [__] room that's 16
[__] rooms
in a pod and when they open up that pod
there's 32 people in there right
wrong there should be
there's usually 26 of them
[__] around in the pod talking
watching tv
gambling
but the other people who know the old
timers the guys who've been in there
before they're in their rooms reading
they're in their rooms doing push-ups
they volunteer somewhere they get out of
that circle jerk
they want you out of that circle jerk
and that's exactly what i did and for me
i don't like reading in my room they had
a library so whenever i had spare time
i went to the [__] library i just
remembered all those things by from
watching odds
i remembered all those things when i
went over the [__] prison
chapter it really affected me prison
like it really did and you guys are at
home going yeah well it should joey what
the [__] no no no no no how many people
do you know that go to jail
and don't go back
how many people go to jail come out and
within a year six you know there's
percentages and the odds are always
against you
the odds i read some [__] when i got
locked up i remember i went to the
university of colorado library before i
got sentenced and i just read up on as
much as i [__] could on you know to
prepare myself i didn't know what i was
getting into you know you see all these
prison movies and [__]
and remember i knew
i didn't know that
i never knew anything about prison i saw
the velocity movie with charles bronson
i saw escape from alcatraz and i
remember being a kid and seeing the
original longer shot i remember being on
my feet and at that point in my life i
didn't have a dream of being a criminal
i was i was joining the army ain't going
to become an attorney and [__] but after
i saw along this yard and saw those
[__] criminals jumping up and down
i'm like that sounds like [__] fun
going to jail and i knew some people
that had been to jail and [__] you know
like at the bar my mother's bar a couple
of guys came in there that had gone to
jail including my stepfather and i
remember talking to them about the
longest yard they're like we don't know
what the [__] you're talking about
nobody plays football in there that's
just a [__] movie a hollywood movie
but
anyway i i always remembered that that
always
struck a chord with me that movie for
some reason i saw
rocky at that movie theater i saw
[__] bruce lee at that movie the the
union city cinema great little movie
theater they didn't ask you for [__]
id they didn't give a [__] how old you
were if you had the two dollars you got
in and the [__] story i saw the
exorcist there yeah tremendous movie did
it some [__] white dude ran in the
[__] 70s and 80s but
that's not what i'm talking about here
joey don't go off [__] track
i'm talking about my prison experience
i knew when i was like 20 that i was
gonna end up in prison when nowhere
i had no [__] idea i just knew i was
gonna end up in my heart
i thought i would go to jail when i was
like 39 and have like a life sentence
that's what i saw when i was 21 22 and
23 that's what i really saw
i've always been the type of guy that
i'm very [__] honest with myself like
you know i'm not gonna [__] you know
was that a funny set no nobody left you
know what i'm saying it's not funny to
get to the real world smoke a joint and
get in the real world i would never be
one of those guys
that comes in with [__] mind [__]
i'm going to be present or whatever
but when i got sentenced to when i knew
i was going to jump like listen i'm just
going to take what they've given to me
go in there with an open heart
you know not let nobody [__] with me i'm
going to be firm
first [__] that [__] somebody
hit them in the head with a chair
so there's no miss on the [__]
standings i mean really that's how you
have to think you know when you walk
into a prison you know in my situation i
went to diagnostic first there's a
thousand [__] guys in there
and they all got a different [__]
agenda for you
so i kept to myself there was this one
black dude i [__] talked with in
there funny as [__] i don't know where
he ended up i still [__] think about
him i still remember what i what he
looked like
uh this guy was hilarious because
he would get on the phone with his
girlfriend he was one of those black
dudes that [__]
yelled at her on the phone and [__]
and he would get on the phone or
something and you could hear him
like in the car you know people talk on
the phone they whisper this brother was
louder than [__]
and he would get on the phone and yell
at her for a little while about god i
had no idea
if i was 20
whatever the [__] i was 26
this guy was maybe 30.
and he would get on the phone and at the
end of every conversation with her he'd
go now
you guys know that in prison nobody
calls you
you got to call them collect
but this guy would always end the
conversation with
listen [__] don't call here no morning
hang up on i go what the [__]
you know like what the [__] are you
talking about
don't call here no more [__] and then
hang up on her
you know you don't expect you think when
you go to prison you're gonna be [__]
sad and miss your people listen you miss
him for about an hour
because once you get to prison you're on
[__] full
lockdown mode you're ready to stab a
[__] you're not thinking about
nobody you lose
all those little [__] [__] emotions
you know you really do because you just
worried about [__] living
you know you saw all these movies you
hear all these things you go in the
[__] shower with a soap wrapped
around your wrist with a string don't
drop the soap [__] i won't it's
wrapped around my [__] wrist with a
[__] piece of soap and [__] with a a
string
i got a little itches butt
when i went to prison man it was for me
it was really a time to rest
like i wouldn't had a rest like to take
a [__] breather
but you know when you watch goodfellas
you know the girls talking to him
lorraine brock was talking and said like
well look at jeannie's husband
you know he he went to jail and she's
like do you know why he went to jail to
get away from genie you know
and i truly believe that i think as you
get older in the [__] system and you
cop like a small like if you're an old
gangster and you cop like a [__]
small thing like conspiracy to commit
you know uh
uh obstruction or something like that
but they put you in jail for a year
which is basically like eight months i
think you look forward to that [__] i
really do when you're in the rat race
because for me as soon as i went in
there i had a high stress level
and after about one once i got to my
location like after two weeks
i rested
i just rested
like it was done there was nothing you
could do what are you gonna escape why
you got [__] two years to do where
you gonna where you gonna go you could
do that standing on your [__] head
i got the job in the [__] kitchen and
something when i was in there like the
first month yeah you don't know you're
giggling you're starting to meet people
you don't know who's who i remember the
first [__] week
i got to camp george west these two new
yorkers
got pinned to me like upstate new york
[__] like i'm a new york city
guy what the [__] do you guys want
sound
yeah from the time i walked in that
[__] prison for the first week i
still remember these two creepy [__]
looking dudes
one of them was short he was like the
the second in command to the other guy
like the other guy would say something
and go what do you think yeah boss let's
do it it was i swear to god it was right
out of the tv show two [__] retards
trying to get over on uncle joey but god
knows what i had no [__] idea what
they were trying to do
i think they were into heroin and [__]
they were trying to sell me the cotton
balls
like when you shoot heroin you you put
the cop i think you you put the cotton
in and you mix it and then you put the
needle into the cotton ball and you pull
the [__] jew juice in and then you
[__] shoot yourself but that cotton
ball has got [__] in it that's worth
money so these guys are selling the
[__] cotton balls like the [__]
scabs of everything
these [__] were selling so
i think after like a week i lost these
guys then i got put in the kitchen
and then i got to tell you guys
something
you ever ever hear people saying like
they got the the best love they've ever
had like this is the love of my life and
all this [__] i gotta be honest with you
guys
because i've had time to think about
i've been watching odds for like three
[__] weeks now so every time i watch
him my wife goes upstairs i turn the tv
off
and i actually think about you know
what happened to me in prison why
and one of the things that happened you
know how people say i i met one of my
great loves i got to be honest with you
guys when i got the
when i got locked down
i ended up meeting one of the best
friends like if i look at my life
in the span of friends that i had
i i bumped into the guy that i thought i
was scared for a while
because i heard all the stories of
people going to prison and coming out a
little street wiser
and then really spreading that in their
horizon and really becoming a full-time
[__]
criminal
[Music]
excuse me i [__] uh
met a guy named toray piles
i don't know
maybe my second week we worked together
in the kitchen good looking dude looked
like michael b jordan same smile
had like a big diamond earring we were
both about the same age
the only thing between the both of us is
he was a [__] professional
drug dealer he was a professional this
guy was making money in the seven digit
range
moving cocaine at my age
he had
seven
count them
seven women
with all different cars with all his
kids
seven kids with seven different women
and they came to visit him three times a
[__] week he would do two visits a
[__] day
and he'd tell the one baby's mama not to
[__] come this guy was the real deal
no jewelry no [__] no
he thought he was cute he was just a kid
who grew up poor in the products of
compton or crenshaw wherever the [__] he
came from
his brother got shot his father got shot
this kid was [__] harder than [__] he
did he wasn't a heavy
he wasn't a bully he was a handsome
[__] young brother
nice build you know just uh
we became friends in the kitchen we had
each other's back
i was the stock clerk i think he was
like the [__] expediter for the food
like he would check with me and that's
how we became friends
and then he moved into my [__]
because all the kitchen people work
lived together that was part of the rule
that if you work in the kitchen
it's better that you live together so
because everybody has to get up at five
in the morning four in the morning and
[__] like that so instead of the cos
going from you know it was like maybe
eight dorms from them going to dorm the
dorm they just put us on the same
[__] army barrack
and that's when him and i hit it the
[__] off i mean i made a lot of good
friends in there
to be honest here but
he was special him and i
we were like [__] freaking frack we
lifted weights together we ran together
we exercised together we ate chinese
food together
we had so many [__] things that we
were friends about like we used to love
nutter butters
he's another butter [__] and i'm
another butter [__] we used to
buy we used to get nutter butters on
sundays and saturdays and stock them up
for sunday night uh
the bundys
america's most won and what were the
bundys love with marriage
on fox that show that was our [__] on
sunday nights
sundays was a big [__] day at the
prison we get an early i got my visits
on mondays and tuesdays alone i was
going to get a piece of ass you know me
married with children so sunday nights
was like america's most wanted the nfl
something else and then marry with
children so wheat stock up with these
two mexican cousins they come in and
every sunday they bring in [__] top
uh tacos
and burritos we clean them the [__] out
my wife would bring my girlfriend at the
time i'm sorry
my girlfriend would bring [__]
chinese food in and then his girlfriend
would bring nutta butters and fruit and
apples and protein powder and his
girlfriend would do the same and on
sunday nights we'd shoot over to that
[__] age unit and we bring food for
everybody and we get them all [__]
hopping the age guys would come out with
their [__] rashes and [__] and hang
out with us there was
four out of five eight guys were in
there like they had five rooms and four
of them were
the age guys win the rooms
it was a black dude that was [__]
hysterical
i never you know i always think about
him and i say a prayer for these
[__]
he was the one that when you were losing
gambling
he would look at you and go
and ain't over to the fat lady sings
but she's busting out of the [__] car
right now he would say all these
he would say all this [__] crazy [__]
then there was this
there was four of them in the age and
there was a black guy that was ready and
they were none of them were gay they
were all [__] uh
babanya shooters you know and they would
talk about
shooting heroin and [__] we go over
there
[__] have platters out
cold cuts it didn't even [__] look
like a prison even the guards would come
and go what the [__] are you guys doing
there on sunday nights
we'd be in there all [__] day
whatever time football started
till 11 o'clock at night and then
something switched like yeah i was
taking some action in there you know you
gotta that's everybody wants to gamble
now i teamed up with this old dude
and i started taking action but i got to
tell you something a lot of people were
doing a lot of [__] weird things in
there but
some things i remember
some i don't but i will tell you
something
i remember at one point like at the
third
month or yeah about the third month in
prison
me saying to myself you know what
yeah i [__] up i came to prison i i
but
that's also the first time i felt
satisfaction of being a man like
that expression being a man i go you
know what i manned up
i could have ran away like a little [__]
and ruined my life forever
i manned up and i manned up because i
never wanted to be in that position
again
i didn't want to be on the hunt i didn't
want cops looking for me
i enjoyed kidnapping people i'm not
gonna lie to you i enjoyed putting guns
out i enjoyed stealing
if you want me to tell you that you know
oh joey stole because he was hooked on
drugs no no i love to tell you that
excuse that's what made me do it but it
didn't
i stole because i enjoyed it at the time
my mind at that time was
the world [__] me over so i'm in
business to [__] the world over now
you know the world hurt me by taking my
mother and you know taking my father at
a young age and you know that was the
[__] excuse i made
i don't think i ever made the excuse uh
knowingly
but i think i made the excuse you know
on the slide that
you know god
dealt me a bad [__] hand and that's
what it really is
i talk to somebody
three or four times a week a dear friend
of mine
he lost his uh mom at the age of 10.
he's told me
so many times about his unhappiness with
god he doesn't believe in god god's a
douchebag
and i want to interrupt and say but i
mind my business because and he's got
two kids you know he hasn't seen the
beauty of life i don't know if it's the
beauty of god or the love of god's hands
or any of that [__]
i just know that my god it's a beauty
when you have children you know and it
really makes you look at life and go huh
whatever i felt before maybe i'm not an
atheist maybe i
but you got to believe in something when
you look at the your kids i know i do
when i look at my daughter
i go you know
maybe i've been conning myself but maybe
the [__] not you know
but after like three months i knew
you know i didn't know
that i was going to stop smoking coke i
just knew that
i wanted to have a life
just a regular [__] life i didn't
want to be in movies or any
i just wanted to be a normal guy i got
up in the mornings i
had a job i had a girlfriend you know
a girlfriend that i didn't do drugs with
you know that she wasn't part of my
[__] criminal
enterprise i just wanted these things
man
i didn't know how i was gonna make money
i was worried but not really
i always had a knack for making just
regular money
but at that point my life 28 i was
already 10 years behind
where all my friends were i was [__]
uh at least that's how i felt
at that time i was 10 years behind
i'm coming out of jail i'm 28 [__] i'm
coming out in 1989
that puts me at 3 27.
i'm coming out of [__] prison at 27 i
got felonies i can't get license for
anything
i can't really get a real [__] job i
could get you know fly-by-night job so
how am i gonna [__] i got no parents i
got no co-signer i basically got nothing
so i'm gonna have to [__] come out
and start i didn't know anything about
goals i loved to tell you at 27
that i knew of the power of the pen i
[__] didn't i just uh
lived my life on the seat of my pants
how a lot of us do
you know
i think there's tough ages when you're
growing up i think the age of like
11 to 14 is tough it was tough for me
you know i was just getting into my
groove at like 12 13 14. my mother died
i was so upset that i had a i had just
gotten into my groove
i had just gotten accepted by my friends
i i was playing basketball i i smoked
dope i did all these stupid [__]
things but i was just
getting into my [__] groove
when
uh when i went to prison i had no
[__] group from the night he landed i
had no [__] drew i was just a
runaway [__] hirakawa you know just a
[__] indian
trying to [__] put the pieces
together i wasn't doing anything
but when i got out of prison i came out
with a [__] purpose
number one
i knew i didn't want to go back in there
again and i ended up going back once
overnight and once for 30 days that's
not bad
after the 30-day thing in seattle i
[__] never went back i never got and
that's
you know when i was mr mean as [__]
but you think about it that's uh 25 20
27 [__] years 26 years without police
contact
but before then you know don't worry
about the police contact 91 i got into
comedy all that [__] but
prison just let me know prison let me
know what i did and didn't want to do
and i knew i didn't want to be a [__]
criminal
i knew that i would have to do a couple
criminal things when i got out
just to get you know balanced out get on
my feet
and you pray to god that you don't get
caught and you don't get in [__]
trouble
i had my [__] fears you know i knew
that
i couldn't stop snoring coke
you know let's be honest with each other
i just [__] knew at that when i got
into comedy i had to make a deal with
myself
either i'm gonna quit coke i'm gonna
quit this struggle
now for anybody who understands the
struggle of quitting anything whether
it's heroin
reefer alcohol it's a [__] struggle
if you tell somebody like i'm gonna quit
cocaine and really quit
at that time i couldn't quit [__]
doing anything i couldn't quit biting my
[__] nails i was gonna quit [__]
doing i couldn't quit anything i had no
[__] self-control so
you know i would go clean for four days
clean for five days
and then [__] up and i would go clean
for four days [__] up
this went on anybody who's been in that
[__] vicious cycle knows that
when you're really trying and when
you're trying to get clean like when you
tell somebody now you got pressure on
you
so now you got some [__] idiot
calling you up every two days how's it
going and you're like right
have you been getting high lately no
never that sucks when you gotta lie to
those people they're not really sponsors
they're just maybe like a cousin or a
[__] a friend of a friend that you
know he got sober and now he wants to
help you
those poor bastards i must have gone
through ten of those [__] when
they call you up hi
i'm friends with michael klein and i've
been clean for 14 months i want to help
you and you talk to them
i tell you really tried to help me get
off coke
and i forget what his name is now mikey
de stefano
you ever hear mikey the stefano
[Music]
jerry roach and him were great friends
and i you know there were so many people
who tried to [__] would pull me aside
there was one dude claude shy as [__]
dynamite he was friends with
kelly kirsten and jimmy schubert when i
got to california
in 98 99
2002. i remember he would talk to me
and then one day he just went full
command on he's like this is what's
going on
i'm gonna pick you up i'm gonna drop you
off at betty four clinic
i'm gonna pay for it when you get out
and get a job and get famous he would
always say that when you get famous
you could pay me back and i'm like
listen i'm not going to [__] betty
ford but
if you lend me a hundred bucks i could
[__] go i got i went through all
those guys and i pray for them now and i
feel bad
and i'm happy that they did what they
did i just wasn't ready yet christos
stefano was probably the last guy
that him and i were having
man-to-man conversations on the phone
mike testa
mikey mikey the stefano
his brothers live in north bergen i
think still good family
good [__] dude funny [__] god
rest his soul
you know he got locked up like me him
and i had uh
a lot of similar stories and i think
jerry hooked this up
and i still he was the closest guy that
got me his i
i say a prayer for him once a week on
mondays
mikey i think about him a lot because
mikey talked me into like the hollywood
free rehab
like hollywood has a free rehab and i
went to it a couple times like i i
joined up i had to give him my license
his name is jose diaz whatever and then
i would go for a week and then and this
is
2 000 guys 2001
2002 i'll never forget going in there
and having a great time and talking i
was going to the to the groups they
would piss you once a week
so i was still at the level where i was
going backwards
like they pissed you the first time and
now all your pisses have to come on to
that level
but i just was like okay and i
i think that i stayed sober for like a
week or two
and then i went to because you have to
go to meetings three times a week it was
like
five a.a meetings
and three group meetings in hollywood
right there it was right there by a
smoothie place i used to go to
and then one day some guy goes hey man i
went to the comedy store and saw you the
other night weren't you there
late night and i'm like no
that wasn't me and i'm like and dog i
[__] got out of there and i was
embarrassed because i didn't want nobody
knowing listen everybody knew i had a
drug problem
but i didn't know nobody i didn't want
anybody coming up to me and trying to be
[__] you know johnny a at the comedy
store
so when i went to get help i didn't want
nobody to find out i was trying to get
help that's the last thing i want is
[__] help last thing i wanted was to
get the other day somebody came a friend
of mine came over here he's in
he's in
the program and he was we were good guy
cop good [__] dude he's a drinker
and we were talking about this comedian
that he goes i saw this comedian that's
drug free and he did a show good guy i
forget what his name is now i knew him
when he was kind i go that dude's a good
dude and he has great material about
heys and [__] but i remember i had a
follow and a couple clubs like he would
come in and i'd come in the week after
him
and the club would go thank god you were
here last
this week
we had a week of [__] aaa people in
this [__] drinking coffee all we
sold was coffee and [__] you know a
couple orders of wings because aa people
used to go into the meetings
so when they would do a show the clubs
would do a show with this guy
they knew they weren't going to get a
toy at a minimum so they just raised the
prices up 10 bucks
and they were like you know they're
happy to be out the guy does an hour on
[__] uh and but that i i still
remember i bring him up
because i remember
thinking if i stop doing [__] coke
that's gonna take the crazy away from me
and i'm not gonna be funny anymore
and that was the reason why i never quit
coke all those [__] years i was
petrified that
my edge was gonna disappear that i
wouldn't be crazy anymore i was [__]
wrong you know we were always wrong
you're still gonna keep
what you're [__] at but anyway back
to toray [__] pow how did we get on
going to [__] rehab in hollywood i
loved it i love all this [__] though
when the podcast goes awry you know what
i'm saying and he's just talking from
the [__] heart on a beautiful
monday morning in [__] new jersey
jack
it's uh
[Music]
yeah the prison
changed my [__] life man
and it should but i tell you it doesn't
work for a lot of people
and when you look at the recidivism rate
of you know doing another crime
it's horrible like people who've gone to
prison they have percentages
that'll make you a [__] head spin
like you won't [__] believe in that's
why
i worked so hard because i didn't want
to fall into that pattern
of being in and out of prison every
three
four five [__] years and then ending
up there for the rest of your goddamn
life that wasn't gonna be me but by
watching us these last two or three
[__] weeks
i gotta be honest with you i'm
i'm happy that i got locked up
and as bad as that sound as [__] as
that sound
dog it was my
and all this conversation started last
week
with me because of bella
i haven't been able to get a hold of a
guy kidnapped
and it's getting under my skin a little
bit i know he takes care of his mom and
you know he lost his job and [__]
and it's so weird when i take
after i got in trouble for the
kidnapping before i got sentenced
i think about how i
felt about vela and i wanted to [__]
kill him
i wanted to kill him
i wanted somebody to kill him you know i
kept saying the victim's gonna disappear
let's not go back
i was mad at vela for something i had
done that's the dumbest [__] thing in
the world
and that's the biggest sign of [__]
immaturity
after i got locked up i saw a vel in a
different [__]
light you know at first i was mad at
villa
i went through a uh a rainbow [__]
emotion for cambella but
the bottom line was that
after i
did that and i'll never forget when i
got out of prison
right before me and my ex-wife broke up
we had an argument about something she
said to me she looked at me
in a way that she had never looked at me
before and she said listen
like you know like when you're arguing
with somebody and something just comes
out and it slips
she goes look at that
you know i can't still believe that you
tied up that boy you tied up that man
and had him in the corner of her room
and she caught herself and she's like
i'm sorry i never really meant to say it
that way and i go no it's okay
it's the truth
you're not speaking out of line here
you're not [__] lying you're speaking
from the heart you're speaking the truth
i can't
believe that i tied up a [__] man and
put him in a corner and
put a pitbull on him or whatever the
[__] tidwell did i was part of it that's
that's the whether i did it or not
that's the sad truth that i'm a [__]
part of that
so when my ex-wife said that to me and
we broke up after that
i started looking i started thinking
about it from tidwell's perspective how
would you feel joey if you want a
[__] floor with a
bandana around your eyes and handcuffed
you know how the [__] would you feel you
know i wouldn't feel any [__] good
like that would stick with me forever
you know and and i don't know if i'm
gonna die when he was in that [__]
floor that kid didn't know if he was
gonna die if he was gonna snort coke
again and knowing him all he cared about
was doing one more [__] line like i
know kent and if i would have put a gun
to ken's head he goes i don't care if
you kill me
just give me one more [__] line
that's the way kent was you know
but uh
over the years i just i built
this love for kent
it went from i can't say hating kent it
went like just from this dumb feeling of
getting arrested with somebody to
because of kent i was i was able to grow
because of what i did to kent
i was able to find what i loved because
of what i did to kent you know all these
things came out
you know it's like kent it's like kent
was like my jesus
you know i'm saying kent had to [__]
get tortured and [__]
for me to have a [__] life so
i've always felt really bad for ken
anytime i could help kent
i do if he needs help with his mom if he
needs help with rent
anything i could do for kent
i do because he opened this up for me i
don't look at him as a guy kidnapped
anymore i look at him as a guy that
helped me change my [__] life
and i'm
you know
i mean i haven't spoken to ken in a
month or so
and you guys see how i am about like i
really care about this guy that
30 years ago just happened to be on the
wrong side of the [__] street
and that's what ended up happening to
him i think about kent a lot so
today i'm thankful for [__] kent
i wish i could do more for kent you know
i live in new jersey he lives in [__]
arizona you know we're [__] time
zones away i wish i could do more for
kent i wish
kent lived around the corner so i could
see him more and take him lunch because
the end of the day
kent wasn't a [__] bad guy
it was he had a kilo of coke and i
wanted it that that's how it turned out
to be how sad is that [__] story you
know and it took me 20 years to get
through them
it
i think that once he realized
that i was growing as a comedian and as
a human being he gave me a second chance
and i [__] loved it i [__] loved
it i loved that i got the chance to
apologize to him
on the church i'm happy that we got to
get a bite together i'm happy all these
things evolved from that because i
turned
a shitty day on november [__] 17th
into
the best day of my [__] life
best day of my life was when i walked
into that fa
and i still remember when i [__] got
sentenced to how i fell asleep in the
cell
after i did a [__] close to a grammar
blow who falls asleep
after doing a grammar blowing a cell i
still remember having to bend over by
the sink
and put the dollar in the bindle and
make believe like
and then dropping the bindle in the
[__] toilet and flushing the toilet
and being high for like 10 minutes but
it didn't matter the the
to
you know me
finding out my uh my fate that day
just overtook everything and overtook
the cocaine it's like [__] it you got to
go to sleep you got to process what the
[__] just happened
so it was really interesting you know so
i talk about this on a monday morning
because sometimes you look at your life
and you go [__] if it wasn't for that i
would have had this no you're looking at
it wrong
you're looking at it wrong
look at it from the perspective that
even this [__] pandemic as much as we
[__]
hate it and the mask and everything
we all got something out of this
pandemic
think about it
you got something to learn about
yourself from this pandemic
or better yet you learn something about
yourself
because of this pandemic
you learn what you could do what you
want to do
what you don't want to do no more for me
it was i didn't want to travel anymore i
didn't want to [__]
really do stand-up anymore i didn't like
what i'd become i didn't like a lot of
[__] things i didn't like that
you know lee was there with me gaining
weight i didn't like a lot of things
and looking all busted out and it all
worked itself out you know so what i'm
not doing stand up i'm healthy
i'm happy my wife is happy my family's
happy my friends are happy you know
and so be it
in the future listen i've been
cracking little stupid jokes to myself
lately i don't know i still got it but
let's just see what the future brings
i'm not putting a a date on anything
i'm just living my life
having a good time trying to analyze and
see what the [__] happened the last 40
years that's all i've been doing the
last year and a half
i got back here we started writing the
book
you know the first couple chapters was
about growing up in jersey and how i was
a criminal and
all this [__] next thing you know
i'm back in the in new jersey i'm
back to where all this [__] went down
i'm back to where all the pain got
[__] caused in my life
and i'm adjusting perfectly and all this
[__] is coming full [__] circle for
me so
when i come out here on a monday morning
and talk to you about my [__] prison
life
it's to let you know that maybe you're
sitting there right now going [__] i'm
stuck no you're not you're not looking
at it from the right [__] perspective
you know sometimes when i go to [__]
needle right like i have to go to get a
needle on a monday i always schedule for
mondays because i'm one of those [__]
type of people
but i'll start thinking about that
needle a week out
and i've learned over the years
that if by two when i start thinking
about the needle if i flip my thought
if i flip it
like
that needle's not gonna hurt i go to
acupuncture once a week i'm gonna be
[__] fine i change my attitude before
i walk on that thing i'm a different
[__] person like i look at it from a
different perspective
you know when i was going to jiu jitsu
i'm a [__] old man
i know i'm going to get beat up
i know somebody's going to tap me 18
times i already know this going in
and i would get this little anxiety as i
was driving to jiu jitsu i had to flip
it around i'm going that
even if i get beat up i'm going to be
[__] better about it even if
no matter what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
[__] learn something
one thing one thing maybe something to
do with breathing
maybe some do my stepping and that's how
i look at things now and it's so weird
between the ages of
20 35 i didn't look at things like this
at all i didn't look at the things for
the good that they had to offer but for
the bad like what i thought was the bad
stuff
it was the good stuff
you know when you're doing hip escapes
yeah you're gonna get [__] tired
you're gonna get out of breath you're
gonna get [__] anxiety but in the
long run your legs are gonna be [__]
strong you know you're gonna it's just
you have to look at things for the
[__] beauty in it sometimes
and trust me for years i was capped in
[__] darkness i looked at things i'm
like i'm not doing that i'm not done now
i gotta switch them up a little over the
years i had to switch them up and look
at it from a different perspective but
this happens with age guys
and i'm going i'm [__] sailing the
i'm sailing the 60 year old metaverse
right now
you guys aren't even
close to me in age i'm i'm i could be
your dad's or i think i could be your
dad if you're up to 40. like if you're
up to 40 i could be your dad i'm 59 i
got to [__] somebody when i was 18.
and you could have been around so a lot
of you guys look at your lives and go
[__] i'm never gonna get through this
this isn't gonna work yes it is
yes it is just put your head down
but most importantly look at it from a
different perspective
look at it from a different [__] view
from a different angle everything has 12
[__] views to it right there's 12
[__] numbers around the clock when i
worked with uh
the guy from stripes and [__] and i did
analyze that and i did that scene when i
feel unpopular that's the first time i
had worked with somebody that used
the 12 o'clock method
the two and ten o'clock method
the three and six o'clock method and the
four and eight o'clock method to shoot
okay so two cameras
first shot we're gonna do is 12. then he
would put two cameras at at two and ten
o'clock so ten and two then he would put
him at nine and three
and four and eight
as the scene progressed as the scene
progressed no no no every scene got shot
like that like that
if it was a small scene just but for you
to shoot that you got to have a big
budget
you know saying like you just can't
yeah you'll be there a [__] day you
got to have a big budget he had a big
budget
it's a warner brothers movie they didn't
give a [__]
for that scene
dawg i that scene started at nine in the
morning and i went to like [__] seven
o'clock at night and it was nothing
it was a nothing scene it was me and
anthony pogba him sitting at a bar with
me
us talking
and all of a sudden we turn look at each
other and he hits my face
and he walks away because the guy comes
in with a gun yeah we could have done
that scene look at here one camera here
one big camera for the whole scene
one on my face one on his face
and shot it all at once no
hal raymus said [__] it i'm gonna shoot
two to ten and i'll never forget like
when we were four to eight we were
taking like a half hour break and i'm in
my ass
i said why do you
i'm not here to question you whatsoever
i'm just learning i love all this [__]
why are you shooting from three to nine
and he goes i won't know because i'll be
honest with you i'll probably throw away
all those [__] things
from tudor whatever but
if i don't see the perspective from
every angle i won't [__] know that
and he goes yeah i could look at it and
hear
and just make like a 50 judgment but he
goes i got to see it on film
to really see what you're missing and he
goes and that's and that's the thing
that we don't do in life we don't look
at it
and trust me i i didn't when i was
[__] 28 if you think i was looking at
things from different perspective you're
out of your [__] mind
that's a practice and today's podcast is
about that practice
that before you attack something look at
it from all the [__] perspectives on
it i swear to god
i started doing this when i was about 38
and it helped me
[__] immensely it slowed me down
in my life it uh
it made me think about things and this
was thanks to my wife
because i had to use this perspective
with everything mike
this perspective had to be used
especially for comedy
you know i still remember i did this
show in bakersfield for these [__]
dudes and
they charged you know
they paid me dollars they paid me
nothing
and they had me do a lot
and while i was doing it i was having a
good time so i didn't mind it i think it
was good karma
you know like he he built it as joey
diaz to me but when i got there it was
the longest yard thing and all these
people were there with footballs or
whatever it doesn't matter but i'll
never forget that
i made a mental note and something i
would never do
like this
thing that i did i probably did this
in 2009 and guess when my career started
in 2010 i started doing comedy in 1991
yeah
but when did my career start
in 2009 or 10 right after i had that
conversation with him the kid's name was
will
i'll never forget i just thought about
all this
and he called me up on there he goes hey
i want to do that thing over again
and all i said to him was in the polite
way i go
i'm in but i go i can't do it for 200
bucks
not for what you paid me that was
charity before i just spoke up for
myself
for years i never said none to those
bookers this time i had to say something
and i said it to him regardless of
whatever was going to go down
i go here's the deal [__]
i didn't call him a [__] because i
wanted him to give me the money i go
listen here's the deal
let's do a [__] door deal
let me promote at that time i knew
nothing about promotions
i was just sick and tired of getting
[__] raped every other week for
comedy
and i go let me get uh let me get a
percentage deal
and he thought about it goes nah you're
not worth it i'll never forget that
and i took it like a man i didn't call
him anything
i just said okay
i'm not worth it but guess what
now because you said that
i'm gonna become worth it because i
understand what i need to do now to
attack it from this perspective when i
got that perspective
was when i started making a little money
and doing comedy
and i'll never forget that three months
later a dear friend of mine called me he
goes hey man
i gotta talk to you about something that
dude
called me and said that uh you're
getting a little bit too big for your
britches
and i was like no i'm not i'm just
asking for my [__] worth
and right after that my career [__]
kicked in the [__]
and right about
what's that
it's a confidence in yourself and you
gotta draw the line and say when
this life changes when you decided to
change
it's not just gonna [__] change
you know
so many things get initiated by you
they're not gonna change just because
you know
so keep that in mind on a beautiful
[__] monday morning because that's it
february is gone [__]
tomorrow is march 1st and guess what the
rent is due [__] it's that [__]
sucking easy i love you [__]
thank you for watching today thank you
for
giving me the love
always and having my back we'll have a
guest for you on [__] wednesday we're
going back to zoom guests whether you
liked it or not you guys had me giving
you hear beatings like eight in a row i
can't keep doing this [__] i gotta
switch it around have some people come
through here
so i love you [__] with all my
heart it's gonna be a great [__] week
i'll be back wednesday march 2nd
i got a birthday on the 5th not my
birthday a dear friend of mine's
birthday on the 5th when is your
birthday
on the 5th yeah see we got 2 [__]
friends on the 5th so it's going to be a
great week this week
uh the [__] cold weather is going
away
that's it
that's it [__] i mean it's a cold
[__] day today here
in new jersey the sad thing about this i
wanted to mention this i had to go to
awake
on sunday for uh the owner of el nido
joe died uh it's [__] devastating i
mean
even rogan saw it on instagram and
[__] called me up and he goes that's
horrible horrible
he passed he was like i said 78 years
old he called coven
god knows what's going on today
i met the guy
i don't know three four five months ago
and uh
he made a big impression in my life this
guy bought a [__] mall when he was 76
years old he bought that restaurant when
he was 75 years old
who buys a [__] restaurant when
you're 75 years old he's a [__] pipe
fitter for christ's sakes
you know he has a pipe fitting company
but
it was a restaurant it was his passion
what he really wanted
and he made it the best he can how the
[__] does a pipe fit up
get a restaurant and make it the top
five restaurants in the state
you know i spoke to my friend uh officer
kelly yesterday in marlborough he goes
the food in there was off the [__]
charts he couldn't believe it
that's what this guy did with his vision
you know when he had a vision
for that mall where it's at to put a
bunch of stuff in there and i gotta tell
you man
in the short time i knew him he made an
impression on me so uh
my heart goes out to him and his family
and if you're by el nido
go in there say hello and say a prayer
because
it's one of the best restaurants i've
ever eaten that in my life so
i love you guys thank you for the
support don't forget ufc this weekend
it's going to be off the [__] hook
and that's it and that's that don't
forget we're releasing
another strand this week i think it's
tremendous or
muchy much i'll keep you guys
five under one so it's gonna be coco
yeah it's so it's coco sashimi
tremendous white truffle
and rainbow runts which is 37 [__]
percent
if that don't get you the cubans will i
love you [__] with all my heart
have a great [__] monday stay black
and i'll see you [__] wednesday
tip
top magoo
kick this [__] meal brother
all right i want to thank you guys
for listening watching whatever the hell
you do you know i love yous all
also i want to thank
cbd lion for always having
our back we've been with them for years
i think they're a tremendous product
you know i've been using the tape on my
knee ever since i hurt my uh surgical
knee again
and i gotta tell you i cut it down the
middle i split it i wrap it around the
bottom tremendous cbd line is the best
whether it's the tincture the tape the
back walls the cream you're gonna love
them
so do me a favor go to cbdlion.com
read up
on the third party lab results you could
start off with the tincture we also have
vapor pens we got the weed listen go to
cbd line get it over with you need cbd
tincture in your life pressing code joey
and get 20 off delivered right to your
crib the joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com
listen whether you run a large business
or a small business
stamps.com is for you if you run a small
business the time and effort you put
into it anything else it's small so time
is money don't waste it
we're going to the post office standing
online
smelling armpits skip the trip and focus
on how to take your small business to
the next level with stamps.com you get
to print official postage right from
your computer and save yourself money
spend less time at the post office and
more time making customers happy
over 10 years we've been with them
tremendous i love stamps.com all my wife
does is measure put it on the post
office raise the stick on the box and
the mailman picks it up bing bang boom
nobody gets their feelings hurry all you
need is a computer and a standard
printer no special supplies or equipment
stamps.com will take care of you get
started in minutes
printing official postage for any letter
any package anywhere
you want to send it stop overpaying
for shipping with stamps.com sign up
with promo code joey for a special offer
that includes a four week trial free
postage and a digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code joey it's that simple now
it's money making time again draftkings
ufc
272 mazda vowel covington oh my god you
got edson barboza on this card
you got my man rafael dos anos
draft king sports book the official
sports betting partner ufc has a
knockout offer for you better dollar on
the main event
and if you win no matter what you get a
hundred and dollars in free bets it's
your lucky weekend [__] you don't
even need the rabbit's foot it could be
a first-round knockout majority draw or
double knockout resulting in no contest
no matter what the [__] outcome is
you get paid and that's with draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner now if there's no gambling
available in your state yet no problem
never fear draftkings is here enter the
ufc 272 pool
they got free pools all you got to do is
answer a couple questions how long the
fight will last who'll walk out the
winner who wears the purple shorts
follow along to track your results
download
the draftking sports book app now right
now
use promo code joey drove down just a
dollar on ufc 272 main event and get 100
and free bets no matter what the outcome
that's it and that's that that's code
joey this saturday at draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner the ufc got to be 21 over
restrictions apply
see show notes for details
with that all in mind just press and co
joey and let's get this deal going so
you can win a little money this weekend
i want to thank draftkings i want to
thank stamps.com i want to thank cbd
lion
and i want to thank
annette for having my back i love you
[__] have a great day and i'll
see you wednesday tip top magoo
[Music]
you